-Nice to see you at number one.
Not too shabby, buddy.
-You know...
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I say before we start --
So, every time I come here,
Jimmy puts a kind of gift basket
in my room,
and it's always so sweet
and thought out.
It's giving me a vinyl.
It's, like, a letter
to my daughter and stuff.
I just want to say
it's really nice. Really nice.
-Aw. Geez. Thank you.
Thank you, man. Please.
I thought you were gonna
make fun of what I gave you.
By the way,
I just want to tell you
that your daughter is just
the most beautiful thing.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations on being a dad.
This is the first time
on the show as a dad.
Congratulations,
you and your wife. Lyra.
-She's back -- She's backstage.
-First time on "Fallon."
-She's the cutest baby.
-[ Audience awws ]
-And me and my wife
had our second date the night --
I did "Fallon" in 20--
I say "Fallon."
I did "Jimmy" in 2015.
And we went out
for our second date that night,
and we just were, like,
reminiscing backstage there.
-Isn't that great?
-Really cool.
-I love that. Good.
There's good vibes here.
She's one.
-She's one, yeah.
-Did she say "Jimmy" yet
or anything?
-No, she does --
She says, "Dada,"
and points at me.
So I'm now like,
"Okay, now she knows."
But before,
she'd just say, "Dada,"
and, like, point at an orange
or something.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Why not? Yeah.
Do you play --- Obviously,
you play music for her.
But do you play the classics?
Do you a big, oh, "Baby Shark"?
Do-do-do-do-do-do?
-We haven't quite got
to "Baby Shark" yet,
but, no, it's --
Very good, by the way.
-What, "Baby Shark"?
Do-do-do-do-do-do?
-Yeah.
Why don't you sing it, though?
Do you not want to --
-My voice hurts.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel you. I feel you.
-Dude, let's talk about this,
by the way.
Another number-one album.
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You cold? Whew.
-I just --
-Wow. You're excited.
Are you cold?
-I just feel the buzz
of number one.
-Yeah, you feel the buzz. Yeah.
-It's in me. It's in me.
-Number one.
Number one, everyone.
I want to say this. Over
a billion streams on Spotify.
A billion.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know,
I read something about you
that I thought was cool.
I don't know it was "Shivers"
or what was --
What was the first single
off this one?
-"Bad Habits."
-So "Bad Habits" was on, yeah.
-Just sending the vibe, Jimmy.
-Yeah, I saw you.
But then "Shivers"
is coming out.
"Bad Habits" went to number one.
"Shivers" coming out,
knocking you --
yourself out of number one
with your other song.
It's like -- Yeah.
And then your buddy
Elton John comes out
with a song with Dua Lipa.
And here's the thing that --
Earmuffs.
Maybe just plug your ears.
Ed's so cool.
He goes through everyone on --
and all his fans and goes,
"Hey. Elton's gonna hit
number one.
He's a good friend of mine.
I want him to hit number one.
So go stream his song,
'Cold Heart.'"
-So, can I interject that?
So the reason --
-Was I close? Was I close?
-But basically --
So, he had started --
When I had my daughter,
he started ringing me
once a week to just check up
on me being a new dad.
And then I had a friend
that passed away,
and then he started ringing me
every day to check up on me.
So we speak --
I spoke to him this morning.
I spoke to him yesterday.
I'll speak to him
tomorrow morning.
We speak every day.
And when his song came out,
he was so buzzed
about being top 20.
And he was like,
"I'm 74, and I'm top 20."
And then it went top ten,
and then it went top five,
and it was climbing up,
and it was the week
where it was gonna go
number one, and I just like --
I would feel like a weird guy
if I was speaking to him
the whole time being like,
"Man, I'm so happy for you,"
but then at the last moment
be like, "[Bleep] you."
-[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah. I'm getting
the number one." Yeah.
"We're friends, but -- Yeah."
-I want -- Yeah.
And we've got a Christmas song
coming out together.
-Wait. You and Elton John?
-Me and Elton John. Yeah.
-He's got one of my favorite
Christmas songs ever.
-Yeah, well, so he --
-"Step into Christmas"?
-Yeah, so, he rung me
on Christmas Day and said --
'Cause he was so buzzed that --
"Step into Christmas"
gets a higher chart position
every single year.
So I think it went in at 13
in the '80s,
and it was like number 6
last year in England.
So he's like, "I want to do
another Christmas song.
Do you want to do one with me?"
And I've always been
quite against --
Not that I don't like Christmas.
I love Christmas.
But in terms of doing
a Christmas song,
you need to chuck
the kitchen sink at it.
If you're going to do it --
-Got to be able to do it.
-I have a Northern Irish friend
that says,
"If you're gonna get done
for stealing a horse,
you might as well [bleep] it."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stealing the horse?
-Yeah.
So I said to Elton. I was like,
"I don't really want
to do a Christmas song
unless we're going in.
Unless it's like -- Unless it's
like sleigh bells, ding-dong.
Yeah, it needs to be
a proper Christmas song."
So I wrote a chorus, and then
I went to go and stay with him.
And we wrote three,
and one of them
was this one called
"Merry Christmas."
Okay. So get this.
So, we write it.
And I title it
"Merry Christmas."
And I'm like, "We're gonna
have to change that title
'cause there's probably loads of
songs called 'Merry Christmas.'"
I went on Spotify, and
I typed in "Merry Christmas."
Nothing. There's "Merry
Christmas, Everyone."
There's "Happy Xmas,"
"Merry Xmas," "War is Over."
There's not a song
called "Merry Christmas."
And then I went on YouTube
and checked it out.
And it baffled me.
Like, there's -- It's kind of
like this glitch in a video game
where no one thought...
-Wow!
-No one thought to -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
'Cause my new horse --
"My new horse." Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Congrats on that song.
Congrats on everything.
You got to come back
more often, buddy.
I miss you, and I love
having you on the show.
Ed Sheeran, everybody.
-Thank you.
-"Equals" is out now.